today the 2009 Nobel Prize for chemistry
was announced and because there isn't a
Nobel Prize in biology the chemistry
prize often goes to people who are
working on the boundary between
chemistry and biology and today was an
example just like that because the prize
went to three scientists for working out
the structure of the so-called ribosome
which is a biological structure that
translates the message from DNA which
gives the genetic information of an
organism into a protein the proteins
that make all our bodies function and
the bacteria and so on the heart of this
Nobel Prize is x-ray crystallography so
perhaps before we look at what the
ribosome does perhaps we'll go and see
what x-ray crystallography is very
convenient it's just next door literally
next door and we could go through here
if the door wasn't locked so the prize
is for working out the structure of a
really complicated molecular system in
bacteria but the basic equipment is the
same for everything and so we've got the
equipment over here where our student
mark is actually aligning a crystal so
the idea is to find out the arrangement
of the atoms of the crystal so here on
the video is a picture of marks crystal
you can see it's quite small compared to
the tip of the thing it's mounted on and
actually in the apparatus you can hardly
see it at all it's right at the tip here
by the tip of my pen and my hand shakes
a lot so you can't even see it so it's
just there and the x-rays are coming out
of this thing that looks just like my
pen this long silver tube hits the
crystal and then the x-ray beam which is
a sharp beam is split up into a whole
series of
beam's which are registered on this
camera here and this camera then
registers a whole pattern of spots mark
can you just show some spots in the
screen so you can see here you can see
this sort of reddish background and then
a number of spots here which are related
to the stretch of the atoms inside and
one of the great problems is how to take
these faults and actually get it into a
form that work can be transformed into
crystal structure and that's one of the
things for which today's Nobel Prize has
been given as the machine works you turn
the crystal Ram so that you can get
different claims of the crystal will
dfrac the light and so you get more
information to get to three-dimensional
structure so now let's go back to the
office and I'll take some my dog toys
and explain what the Nobel Prize was for
the Nobel Prize was given for solving
how bacteria make take the code genetic
code in DNA and convert this into
proteins now in DNA there is a chain
which has little groups on it rather
like these packets on this rod and the
order of the groups is a code which is
translated into the links of the chain
of a protein so here you can see we've
got black green black and then here
we've got green black black black green
green and so on and you can imagine
these groups of three markers on the DNA
will translate into a particular amino
acid or amino acid as some people say in
the link protein and a protein is a
chain of amino acids one attached to
another and which have formed in a long
chain and then when you form the chain
it automatically spontaneously wraps up
into some
quite complicated structure not
necessarily this structure this just
happens to be a toy but you can see you
get too tightly packed mass and the
question that people really wanted to
know was how this part of every cell
called a ribosome actually translates
this code into that chain and the first
thing was to take the ribosome and
actually turn the Mallette molecules of
the ribosome which has really two big
molecules and get them to form crystals
so the first part of the nobel prize was
given to an israeli scientist at a unit
she took bacteria from the dead sea
where it's very salty and these
particular bacteria she managed to get
to crystallize and get crystals which
would give a pattern of spots like we
saw in the x-ray machine the ribosome
was known to consist of two parts a
small part which translates this and a
larger part on the top that put that
gets the protein and the protein now we
now know comes out as it's being made
like a channel at the side of this large
part and the first part of the problem
of solving this was how to take these
spots from the x-ray pattern and turn
them into a structure and it was the
second oprah nobel prize winner tom
states who comes from the states who
managed to work out the structure i
believe of the large part and then the
small part was worked out by the other
two prize winners the third one being
professor Ramakrishnan who comes from
the laboratory of molecular biology in
Cambridge now I might have got this
wrong two of them did one part one did
the other so eventually instead of
knowing that these were blobs they got
them structures down to the individual
atoms so you could actually see how all
the atoms were arranged the next
question was how does this machine work
so it doesn't make any mistakes because
you can imagine here the code is going
through the bottom parts and the chain
is coming out and if you reading
something fast you sometimes read the
wrong word and if the protein if the
ribosome makes a mistake you get the
wrong protein and things were just won't
happen and so this is where
Ramakrishna's work came in because he
showed that within this structure there
was a probe which is now known as run
the christian's ruler that's an
arrangement of mole atoms which can read
along this thing rather like my fingers
so not only that it can identify which
of the bases in in the DNA or the
so-called RNA that is used that that
goes into the ribosome and so it can
tell black from green to yellow but at
the same time it can actually measure
the distance between them so it can make
sure that it really does but identify
them properly and it makes very few
mistakes